Here's a crazy thought. You don't have
to be online to create an online
business. Let me explain. Four years
ago, when I started building my creator
business, I spent about eight to 10
hours a day online, replying to
comments, writing, posting, [music]
recording, scrolling all day long. And
then I realized that I was just turning
my creator business into another job and
and I didn't want to. Fast track to
today, 90% of my creator business is
done offline. And I do it in about three
to four hours a day instead of eight to
10 hours a day. Which I know all the AI
bros are out there like, "Bro, I could
do it in 10 minutes a day." Yeah, dude,
we can tell you do it in 10 minutes a
day. But besides the point, in this
video, I'm going to give away everything
that I'm doing to help you make money
online without having to be online and
do it in about half the time than 99% of
the other people out there. And if I
haven't met you, my name is Allan Dragu.
I'm a copywriter and a content creator.
I've made over $2 million for my clients
writing copy for them and well over
multiple six figures for myself doing
content creation online. This is what I
do all day long. All right, let's stop
dillydallying and let's dive right into
the juicy stuff. The first way of
reclaiming your time and spending more
time offline in your creator business is
you have to understand the system that
the creator economy grows in. The system
that I use is my framework that I call
the ARM funnel, okay? ARM stands for
three things. It stands for audience,
relationship,
okay? Bad drawing. And [music] then
money, okay? Audience, relationship, and
money. And those three phases are your
big needle movers. If what you are doing
does not increase the amount of people
following you, your relationship with
those people, and how much money you're
making in the whole ecosystem, then what
you're doing is not important. It is not
a needle mover, as I would call it. So,
you got to pare down everything down to
does it grow my audience? Does it build
my relationship? Does it make me more
money? If it doesn't do any of those
things, it's a waste of time, okay? So,
now let me show you break down each
individual one what that looks like. So,
the biggest thing, this is the biggest
thing that most people waste an enormous
amount of time and this is where you're
going to spend most of your time online
instead of offline where you're going to
get fatigued in the comments and all
that crap, okay? So, check this out. The
biggest thing that most people do is
they go online and they hear these gurus
and they're like, "Post as much as you
can. Engage. Be the reply guy all day
long." So, post engage, post engage. And
oh my gosh, bro, what do you think I
have? You think I got 10 hours a day to
stroke these people's egos? No, I do
not, okay? So, I'm telling you to do
something completely different. You
don't go on Instagram and Twitter and
Threads. Oh lord, stay away from
Threads. And all these platforms and you
start just reply guying and all this
stuff. Nobody likes that. It's annoying.
You hate it, they hate it, equally hate,
okay? You don't want any of that. What
you actually want to do is you want to
stay away from what I would call these
algorithmic platforms, especially those
ones based on engagement. Everything
that I just said is an algorithmic
platform. One that if you stop engaging,
they will stop boosting you, okay? Those
ones value you spending time on the
platform more than quality content. What
instead instead of algorithmic
platforms, you want to look for what I
would consider evergreen platforms,
okay? An evergreen platform is one that
you could do my favorite thing, which is
post [music]
and ghost, okay? You want to be able to
post a really high quality piece of
content, whether it's an article or
video or whatever. You want to be able
to post something and then let the
content speak for itself. If that is
good content, it should be able to gain
traction based on people experiencing
that content. Or I suppose you could
have some really dumb people on Threads
who are who have massive followings
simply because they reply and
regurgitate a bunch of platitudes.
That's you can't build a business off of
that. So, some platforms that may help
you realize that you can post and ghost
[music] are my three favorites, YouTube
being the number one, okay?
And then podcast being number two.
And number three is Medium, all right?
There's three different volumes. I use
these three because this one is
primarily video, this one is primarily
audio, and this one is primarily
writing. But the thing that these all
have in common is that you can post
quality content and people can find it
way way way way down the line. YouTube
is kind of the king at this, all right?
You can post a video and then five years
later, it's still getting views and
clicks and email subscribers and YouTube
subscribers and all this stuff because
YouTube is a search engine. So, people
come to YouTube to look for specific
things, especially educational content
like this, which is exactly why I spend
the majority of my time building for
YouTube, okay? And then the next one is
podcast. Again, podcast is searchable
content, evergreen. People can listen a
podcast from months ago. It doesn't it's
not based on an algorithm that you have
to reply to anybody. So, you can post a
podcast and then boom, move on with your
day. Same thing with Medium except it's
written for. Medium, you can post
articles and articles and articles. And
I'm going to give a subsidiary shout-out
over to Substack. Substack has a
Medium-esque
vibe to it where you can post articles
and build email subscribers, but
it's honorary shout-out simply because
it does require some engagement if you
really want to grow on Substack. Based
on their like timeline Twitter feature
and their notes, right? Where you could
just like post notes and things like
that. They really want you treating it
like a Twitter if you're going to grow
on it. But you could technically just
post an article once a week and you
would still grow. You would just grow a
lot slower. Medium again is a good
written platform. If you're going to do
it, I would do Medium, Substack, and a
blog on your own website so you can get
SEO content. So, if you're a writer, I
would do all three of those and just
repurpose the content across the board
so you can get that evergreen effect
multiplied. But other than that, if
you're willing to, you could do YouTube,
which also doubles as a podcast. You can
export that audio. And and just use one
of these evergreen platforms. So again,
you're not baited on engagement, all
right? Now, here's the thing with all of
this. Any of these platforms, you can
record offline, okay? You don't have to
be native inside of YouTube or Medium or
Substack or whatever else, podcasting.
You can record it like I'm in my home
studio right now recording this video.
I'm not on the internet. The content
that I am creating is done completely
offline, okay? I write, record,
research, edit all of this stuff
offline. I'm not scrolling timelines.
I'm not replying. It's not how I grow
this channel. It's not how I grow my
business. I grow by creating. And that's
what all of these platforms are done.
You can record audio like this
completely offline. You do not need to
be on the internet, okay? Medium
articles, blog, Substack, you can write
completely offline. In fact, let me show
you something. One second. Look at this,
okay? This is a typewriter, but it's a
smart typewriter. It's a digital
typewriter, okay? It is beautiful. It is
sexy, all right? I write all of my
content on this typewriter and then when
I'm done with it, I hit send and it goes
to my email and then I edit it and
schedule in my email software
to send that stuff or my content, my
tweets, anything like that. You can do
this stuff offline. Doesn't that make
sense? Isn't that amazing? Then you
could just schedule it with a scheduling
platform. You spend the least amount of
time on these platforms. You move on and
you go to the next phase, which is
relationships. Relationships is what you
want to do to expand your audience
because Kevin Kelly teaches us that to
have a thriving online business, what
you really need is you need a thousand
true fans. You don't need a million
followers. You need a thousand true
fans. A true fan is somebody who's
willing to buy anything and everything
you put out because they like and trust
you. They love what you're doing. People
will buy my stuff because they like and
trust me, right? There's a million
content creators out there and
copywriters and all that stuff, but you
connect with the personality, the
relationship. Oh, I like this guy. He's
got a family or he's Christian or he's
in good shape. He's incredibly good
looking. Yes, yes, all of those things.
And so, really there is a deeper face to
just building an audience online. Like
on YouTube, me and you are building a
relationship right now. But if you
really wanted to have a much deeper
relationship with me, you would be on my
email list, okay? My email list is where
I send daily emails where I teach deeper
lessons than I teach on my YouTube
channel and I tell deeper stories and
you get more context and more
background. And it is a personalized
experience of L me. And that's exactly
what you need to be doing. So, your
funnel may look something like this,
which is a lot like mine, which is
YouTube to email. And so, people watch
your videos, you post a lead magnet on
your videos where you say, "Hey, if you
are into golf content because let's say
you're doing a golf YouTube channel.
Hey, if you're into golf content, then
you're going to absolutely love my five
at-home golf exercises to hit your
driver a thousand yards," which is
theoretically and physically impossible.
But let's say you figured out how to do
it, okay? They give you their email
address to hop onto your email list. And
every day, let's say every day cuz I
send a daily email to build a
relationship with people. Or let's say
once a week or three times a week,
whatever it is, you are showing up in
their email inbox and you are growing
your relationship. The reason that email
has a better relationship rate than an
audience online is because email is
personal. It's one-on-one. They get an
individual email from you separately. I
know most people know that it's going
mass to thousands of people. That's
okay. It feels one-on-one to them,
especially when you write the way that I
write, which if you are not currently on
my email list, I want you to head over
to allandragu.com
and join my email list. I guarantee you
will be blown away by the quality of the
emails that you get every single day in
my inbox. And if you don't, you can
unsubscribe happily, but I guarantee you
will be blown away. And while you're on
my site, go check out the stuff page,
right? alandragu.com/stuff
and I have a bunch of free stuff for you
to join my email list. Books, contents,
templates, all that stuff. You're going
to love it. Here's the kicker. All those
emails that you write, you can write
offline. Okay, you can turn the Wi-Fi
off on your laptop. You can turn the
Wi-Fi off on your iPad. You can get a
cool typewriter like I just showed you a
second ago and write completely offline.
In the backyard, in the sun, at the
cafe, doesn't matter. You do not have to
spend a single second online to write
your emails. You don't have to design
them. You don't have to put pictures in
them. You don't have to do any of that.
You could just write a short story every
single day about what you are doing to
grow in your niche. Again, if we're in
the golf niche, you could write a short
story about how you were playing 18
holes yesterday and you learned this
lesson and it was a great time and that
was the story for today and that's how
you're going to teach them and then you
upsell your product, which leads us to
the final thing, which is money. Your
creator business has to make money
somehow and there are two ways that I
would highly recommend you invest in
making money for your business. And
those only two ways is what I would
consider a paid newsletter or a paid
community, okay? Now, this is where the
last 10%. Remember at the beginning of
the video, I said 90% of my business is
done offline. Well, 10% of it is done
right here. It's really the paid
community. I have built a paid community
on school called the copy creator club
where I help copywriters and creators
fire their clients, fire their bosses
and build a full-time lifestyle business
in the creator economy using writing,
which is exactly what we're talking
about today. So, if this is helpful for
you and you really like it, then you can
click a link in the description below to
check out copycreatorclub.com.
See if it's helpful for you where I'm
actually going to help you hands-on in
the community build it out. And if you
want to see what other people think
about it, scroll down on that page and
the link and you'll see some incredibly
kind words from people who are already
in the club and growing their clientless
business. Shameless plug. But a paid
community is one of the ways that you
can make money or a paid newsletter. The
reason I go with these two options is
because the revenue is recurring, okay?
You want something where they're paying
you a subscription. This is what blows
up most things is most people are like,
I want to do courses and sell PDFs and I
want to do
cohorts, launches, right? They're doing
all this stuff. But here's the thing,
the revenue looks like this. I've done
it, okay? You got highs and lows. You do
a launch, money's up. You're not doing a
launch, money's down. You do another
launch and it's just fatigue after
fatigue after fatigue. You need
something that you can build revenue off
of. Just because you made 10 grand one
time, doesn't mean you make 10 grand a
month. Now you got to go do that same
thing again and again and again.
Instead, what if you built a newsletter
that cost $10 a month and you got 100
people to join that $10 a month
newsletter? Well, it makes you $1,000 a
month. So now, all you got to do is
scale that to the number you actually
need, okay? So, the $10 a month, now
let's say you got 1,000 people in it.
You say, well, I got to scale that to
1,000 people times $10 a month and
that's how I hit $10,000 a month, okay?
So, that's one way to make 10 grand a
month, which is six figures. It's a good
income, right? It's not bad. Not my
preferred. I want a little bit more meat
on the bone, you know what I'm saying?
But let's go down to this. Okay, so
let's say you got a low ticket
community. Let's say you run a ticket a
low ticket community like mine. I charge
$50 a month to be inside of copy creator
club, which is by far one of the best
low ticket I got I can't believe I
haven't double tripled the price for the
for the content that I'm delivering in
there, for my presence.
All right, but let's look at this. Okay,
so $50 a month times 100 people, okay?
So now, you're making 5 grand a month
with 100 people. Let's say you get 200
people times 50, now you're making 10
grand a month, okay? So, all that with a
low ticket community or a low ticket
paid newsletter. And so, what a full
funnel may look like for you is it may
be YouTube to your email list to your
low ticket
community. And then from there, you
realize that if I'm not growing my
YouTube channel by creating content,
writing a daily email or serving my
community, it is a waste of time. And so
now, you can have a focused three to
four hours a day that's either creating
content here, writing emails here or
building this here. And you realize that
anything outside of this is a complete
waste of time. So, you're not spending
eight to 10 hours a day speaking here,
teaching there or building this or
writing that or trying this or running
ads or whatever. You don't have to waste
any of your time doing it because you
have focus. You say, this is my funnel,
this is how I'm going to build it and
this is what works and I just have to
scale it and it takes time. This right
here that you can't do this overnight,
okay? This is not like, okay, fantastic.
Is this my 30-day plan? No, muchacho.
This is like a three-year plan, okay? If
you want to learn how to build a YouTube
channel, grow an email list and then
sell a low ticket offer, that stuff
takes time, okay? This is not some AI
guru workshop. This takes some serious
effort, some serious work. And if you're
willing to put in that serious work and
you want to have your own internet
business where you work at three to four
hours a day and it supports your family
and it's a good business, something that
you love, then consider, again, copy
creator club is the spot where I can
help you and be your coach to do that.
But if you're looking for like that
30-day fix, dude, go look at the drop
shipping boys on TikTok. I think they're
still stroking their egos over there.
You can go you can go play with that.
But if you want to do real business and
you like the way that I do business,
then I highly recommend checking it out,
joining my email list, hanging out, like
and subscribe this video first and
foremost. I'm asking you to do a lot of
stuff.
I like it. But like and subscribe this
video, hang out, check out my other
content. This right here is the starting
point, the launching point. This will
get you going. I hope it was helpful and
if you need anything else, drop a
comment. I probably won't respond
because I
I couldn't even finish that sentence.
Look, I respond to my emails and I
respond to my community, but other than
that, I'm offline. I'm hanging out. I'm
playing golf. I'm in the backyard. I'm
hanging out with my kids. If you like
the sound of that, subscribe to this
channel and I'll see you on the next
one.